so for you to tell me that the gospel or
the has been made crooked so to speak
and that means you would have an idea of
what the straight line was right of what
theil actually said you know what
actually yes what what the Quran says so
that means that you wait wait the Quran
is is the in no whatever whatever
message was brought on to every Prophet
from before has for example the belief
in one
God okay the believe in his angels the
believe in
[Music]
does the Quran tell you that that the
said anything about Hell or Heaven what
do you mean the Quran no no no the point
I'm trying to make here is that whatever
was prescribed before to the previous
prophets how do you know what was
prescribed to them when you don't when
you don't have a straight line how do
you know when a when because the Quran
finalized it the Quran said it is the
last message is going to be
unchanged so what what is your reasoning
for saying that the Bible is reable well
you believe that B is reliable too
unfortunately I don't I don't believe
the Bible that we have today is reliable
yeah you do no I don't prove to me that
I do what language did Jesus speak where
did Jesus speak he spoke aramic where
did you get that from what do you mean
where do we get that aramic from aramic
is a language how do you get aric from
like where do I get the information from
it's history it's known that it was what
did you get that Jesus spoke Aramaic
from the original language that Jesus
spoke in his vision was
aramic aric yeah how do you know it's
it's common history that people should
know what history what where what what
what is a historical source that tells
you that Jesus lived in a region where
he was speaking Aramaic oh this person
but what is your reasoning of saying
what language you spoke if you were
talking when you were paused when you
were off the app I couldn't hear you bro
so you said something sorry sorry sorry
what I was saying is like I can't bring
I'm not a student of History I can't
bring anyone saying that oh Jesus would
Aramaic what I have read up on has
taught me that yes he spoke Aramaic what
is your reasoning of you read no when
you make a claim you have to provide
evidence what is your what is your basis
what source are you using to say that
Jesus spoke aric from what I have read
up and understood okay I I don't have
specific authors I can't just name you
all the authors that I have read about
that being like Oh Jesus spoke Aramaic
from what I have read from what the
information that I have sure I can lack
knowledge in that sense but from what I
understand he spoke our okay so I can
tell you where you get it from can I
tell you sure tell me you get it from
the New Testament okay do we have the
Aramaic version of do we have the
original Aramaic version of the New
Testament the whole version hold on
where do you get this from that the New
Testament was originally anic where do
you get that from from scholarly works
that have shown
that show me what scholar what scholar
tells you that's what I'm saying I can't
name you specific authors and specific
scholarly works but I can tell you from
what I have you shouldn't say that you
shouldn't say you shouldn't say okay no
no okay okay listen if you are if I'm
making claim yes I can say I can lack a
knowledge if you're saying that okay
like you're trying to like Rebus the
claim
okay not rebutting your claim I'm asking
you to justify your claim like for
example if I'm I'm a theist let's let's
let's if I'm having a conversation with
an atheist and I I both me and an
atheist believe that morality is real
morality exists now as theists we
justify morality we say that it comes
from from God whatever innate morality
that we have exactly but for an atheists
they cannot they don't have a basis or
foundation on for Morality so they can't
justify it so even though we agree that
morality is real and it exists the
atheists can't justify whereas I can
same thing for you you're a Muslim I'm a
Christian um we both believe that Jesus
spoke Aramaic
I can justify it but you can't see
that's the point I'm trying to make so
what I have read okay I I can't name you
every author that I've ever read about
like I can't name every paper that I've
read about okay I've I'm I'm a doctor so
I've read out like so many like you know
like research papers like it doesn't
mean I remember every author ever I know
okay there's the information in my brain
that yes he spoke Aramaic so you trying
to say the point I'm trying to
understand is why are we stuck on did he
speak Aramaic or not what I'm trying to
AR if we both agree if we both agree
that he spoke Aramaic let's move forward
from that well no that because it's not
just about agreeing it's about the
justification for why we say that see
remember I started this off by saying
I'm going to prove to you that you rely
on the Bible and this is what I'm doing
the reason why you know spoke Aramaic
only place the place you get it from or
whatever author told you that Jesus
spoke they get it from the source is the
Bible it's the New Testament okay again
same that that that does not mean
somehow that the Bible is accurate does
it though it does because you just one
point just one point in the just cuz
you're making one point saying that oh
we get because arama was spoken by Jesus
and the Bible was written in Jesus
that's why it's accurate that does not
make
sense criteria for accuracy criteria for
accuracy includes you're missing it I am
telling you I'm asking you for the
primary source where does it come from
that he spoke Aramaic and the answer to
that is the New Testament so you're
relying on the New Testament as a
historical Authority on the language of
Jesus you're ring on and I have never
denied listen again again no muslim
would ever deny that the inil that was
brought on to Jesus was a lie the Bible
that we have today
is who listen theel that was brought to
Jesus the original scripture that was
brought down to Jesus was not Al lie
because that was the law given to go
from God to Jesus the the thing that we
disagree on the Bible that we have today
has Corruptions that's the only
difference
that to Jesus absolutely not not the
exact so you bringing up this inil of
Jesus is irrelevant I'm talking about
the Bible and I'm proving to you that
you rely on the
Bible does it mean the gospel does it
mean the gospel does mean the gopel
you're right yes is what I have that
gospel you don't have the Gospel of
Jesus you have the gospel of whoever the
writers were
of so bringing guess what then bringing
up this mystical Lil that you're talking
about that Jesus had is not is
irrelevant because I'm not talking about
that apparently I'm talking about the
Bible the new testament which is not
that so please focus on the New
Testament you
said let me land this and show you why
this is important the reason why this is
important is all on the fact that I said
even you rely on the Bible that I have
you said no I don't I said I can prove
it to you you said how and this is where
we're at showing that the very fact that
you're pulling from that
Jesus comes from the Bible that I have I
specifically said not the exact same
even in the time of Muhammad prophet
Sall Al wasallam they used to use the
inil whenever it agrees with the Quran
that's the point I'm trying to make here
listen wait wait who who did that the
prophet the prophet and his companions
the prophet and his companions have have
agreed show me show me when mam okay
absolutely no problem yeah sure show
show me when Muhammad used the gospel
that we have and and see again the
gospel that we have the gospel we have
is not the same the whole issue the
gospel we have the gospel we have as in
me and you in in the year 2024 is not
the same as the gospel that was given to
Jesus no no is it the same gospel that
Muhammed had access to who knows because
it's gone through so many updates my
iPhone's gone through more updates than
like my
I want you to pay Abdullah pay attention
to what you're saying my dude you keep
flip-flopping everywhere pay attention
you're not making one point you're not
making one point I'm trying to help you
I'm trying to help you bro if you just
listen and relax you'll be fine you'll
be just fine I promise dude you're
saying that what I have is not what
Muhammad had access to and it's not what
Jesus had access to fine I grant that to
you I never made that claim I never
brought that up all I said was is that I
can prove to you that you rely on what I
have on what I'm using that's the point
so if
you're let me let me finish so that you
understand what not to say so you
bringing up that what I have is not the
Gospel of Jesus or not the gospel that
Muhammad was pulling from whenever he
felt like it is irrelevant because I
never made that claim my point is that
you rely on the same thing that I am
using so you saying that Jesus spoke
Aramaic comes from the book that I am
using you get it see I understand the
point you're trying to make but that
still does not make the point go forward
that's the whole argument here we're
stuck on one point about oh because I'm
using uh what do you call uh the new the
New Testament as Jesus speaking aramic
that's why Jesus Is God that's not the
point I'm trying to make see when we're
trying see if a scripture okay that
wasn't the point that's the whole that's
the whole point you're trying to make is
that if I'm using the new test if I'm
okay let me just clarify that we're on
the same page let me just clarify okay
yeah let me just clarify that let me
just clarify okay just make sure that
we're on the same page yeah you're
saying that I'm using the New Testament
as a source right am I using to find out
to find yes to find out if Jesus spoke
Aramaic thus making thus making the New
Testament that we have accurate that's
what you're trying to say according to
your own standard that's what you're
trying to say but that's not the
standard I put up that's that's the
whole reasoning that's why I'm trying to
make I'm showing you that you yourself
use the Bible as your standard of
authority on the life of Jesus what what
part of that people use people use
Aristotle as like a as a the like what
do you call as a source of like
Authority people use like PL does not
that does not make that does not make it
real not make it like it happen
embarassing down you're going down do
people use Aristotle stop do people use
Aristotle as a source on the life of
Jesus that's not the point I'm trying to
make the point
I'm do they use they don't no they don't
no they don't no they don't no they
don't what do they use as a as a
historical Source in the life of Jesus
what do they use primarily what we use
is the New Testament what's your point
so do you see how I just proved to you
that you use as your Authority on the
life of Jesus the Bible that was my
whole point which is why which is why
hold on which is why the Bible is on the
table on whether or not Jesus claimed to
be God so so so so what you're saying is
there is no other source that can show
that Jesus spoke Aramaic basically
besides the New Testament no no besides
the New Testament no no I'm trying to
understand your point besides the newest
let me there is no other primary source
that tells you that Jesus spoke Aramaic
there will be secondary and tertiary
sources but no primary source other than
the New Testament that puts Jesus in the
first century that puts Jesus in the
region where Aramaic was the was the
language of the Jews that puts Jesus in
the in the time in the synagogues
reading in Aramaic and in Hebrew it's
the primary sources the only primary
sources that we have nothing else again
I just want to clarify so it's for my
own knowledge does the New Testament
itself okay said that Jesus spoke AR I
just want to for my own knowledge okay
it does okay so what you're saying okay
is that's the only primary source that
we can use there's no other source that
we can use there is no other primary
source other than the New Testament on
the life of Jesus the New Testament is
the only hear me out the only primary
source that we have on the life of Jesus
okay I understand your point but again
that see that's where we're stuck at
that's the whole point I'm trying to
move forward from you are basing your
belief and my apparently like my belief
at the same time primary sources what
was me brother brother brother you're
trying to assume that the only thing the
only criteria I'm using is Jesus
speaking aramic and that's the only
criteria I'm going to use that the Bible
is accurate brother that's not the whole
point historically list let let me let
me let me let me make three criterias
let me at least make three criteria so
we can move forward okay historically
okay if the Bible is accurate then we're
moving forward with it second is how how
reliable it is in terms of preservation
of the Bible itself okay from over the
years okay not just I'm not just talking
about the that we have now or revised
this many times or like taken these many
sources no no I want the original Bible
that was there or the oldest Bible that
you have compared to the newest Bible we
have okay let me make my third Point
okay and the third point will be this
this is from a Muslim standpoint okay is
the accuracy okay of the events in terms
of like the accuracy of how we perceive
what Jesus is is he a God is he a Son of
God is he part of the Trinity is he not
part of the Trinity or what what like
what he is to us as a Muslim as just a
prophet these are the three criteria
you're you're trying to say that oh just
because Aramaic that Jesus spoke Aramaic
that's the reason no no no I'm not
trying to base my criteria on that
that's the whole point all right brother
whoever said death scree Scrolls in the
in the comments by the way you f focus
on me don't Focus Fus focus on so
Abdullah um when you say that Jesus
spoke a MAG is that a historical claim
historical fact based on what just just
the New Testament don't ask me a
question when I just asked you a
question yeah no okay no no I'm agreeing
but I'm saying it's just in the New
Testament so what is the do you have
another primary source that tells you
Jesus spoke Aramaic the at the time of
Jesus that's what the language of the
area spoke how do what does you want how
do you know how do I know that how do I
know that because there are carbons in
rocks that show that they spoke Arabic
there's Scrolls from that time period
there's scrs from that time period what
do you mean show you like would you want
me to come to your house and bring you
some scroll show your screen on and show
me show me the let let me let me let me
actually like Google this right now for
you and find it for you okay are you
going to can can I use Wikipedia or are
you going to be like oh this is not an
accurate Source well you can use
Wikipedia I'll allow it but hopefully
wikip just making sure just making sure
sources yeah they they usually Source
their in there so I'll find it for you a
common language based on what I'm trying
to find sources and I will find any
sources that's not the issue all right
let me let me give you something else
you ready sure hit me with it how did
did Jesus pray how did he pray please do
tell me cuz I'm I'll tell you from what
I understand in the Bible don't don't
bring up the
Bible what what what Muslims what
Muslims say is how would every the Jews
prayed at that time that's how you
prayed but that's what we remember what
we are told or what we are explained how
did he pray and we by putting his head
on the ground where do you get that from
by bowing down where do you get that
from how am I supposed to know the maybe
the Old Testament May the Jews and and
how they used to pray like what's your
point the Quran doesn't say that no I
know the Quran doesn't say that I that's
not the point I'm trying to make I'm
trying to what I'm trying to say is like
that's that's what I yeah okay if you
want to go to the Hadith we can go to
the Hadith too that's not they don't
they don't say that so where do you get
that Jesus put his head to the ground
and prayed where do you get that from
again listen I can't name you my
specific sources but if you want to go
by okay yeah go for it the Bible again
it's two for again that's that's that's
the whole issue and again it's not two
for two again first of all you are
facing brother brother you're basing
like saying like oh everything in the
Bible is true what I'm saying is not
everything in the Bible is true some of
the things in the Bible is true because
brother every Muslim believes every
Muslim brother every Muslim believes
this and every Muslim knows this the
Torah and the inil the original ones we
don't have them there have been changes
from here and there because of
translations or whatever errors people
made or whatever how do you know what a
CR line is how do you how do you know
what a how do you know what a crooked
line is when a line is crooked how do
you know it's CR when the line is
crooked it's it's not straight what do
you mean the line is crooked you can see
when the line is crooked it's not
straight so that means that you have an
idea of what a straight line is to know
what a crooked line is right okay what's
your point so for you to tell me that
the gospel or theel has been made
crooked so to speak and that means you
would have an idea of what the straight
line was right of what theel actually
said you know what actually yes what
what the Quran says so that means that
you wait wait the
is the in no whatever whatever message
was brought on to every Prophet from
before has for example the belief in one
God okay the believe in his angels the
believe in hell and heaven the believe
in the believe in where does the Quran
tell you that inil that the inil said
anything about Hell or Heaven what do
you mean the Quran no no no the point
I'm trying to make here is that whatever
was prescribed before to the previous
prophets how do you know what was
prescribed to them when you don't when
you don't have a straight line how do
you know when a when because the Quran
finalized it the Quran said it is the
message it is going to be the unchanging
is going to sorry guys I know it's
Frozen on YouTube trying to fix it but
anyway because the Quran says it is the
final message okay and it is the
unchange message it the final message
for for for every for every the reason
why I'm cutting you off is because
you're not answering my question I
didn't ask about what the Quran is I
asked about what the inil is what it
says how do you know what was in
what was in the the worship of one God
that's the basic that's the basic
principle of of of what the what was in
like if you want to go to the first
message that every Prophet would have
got is the belie say you don't know bro
I would I would honor you more if you
just said no no you tell me you tell me
you tell me brother brother you say you
don't know you tell me then you tell me
if you know so much wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait a second no notice how no
no notice the notice this did I say that
the gospel was changed or did you I said
the gospel is changed so is it upon me
to show how the gospel is not changed or
is it upon you to show how the gospel is
changed because I made the claim so I'm
going to show how the gospel is changed
obv so with you making the CLA every
time every time every time every time I
made a point claim that the gospel is
changed that means that you know what
the gospel originally says right which
is personified by what the Quran says
what what's your point Y man you about
to get you about to get booted you about
to get booted cuz you're just a Rob
because no no because you're trying no
no you're trying to get some words out
of me where does the Quan say that Jesus
prayed with his head to the ground and
that's in theel again I never said that
Quran says that Jesus playay with his
head on the ground we say we say all the
stuff that you steal from the Bible is
amazing isn't it you steal from the
Bible but then argue against what kind
of world is this brother you're you're
again you can throw whatever insults you
want or anything in there you're not
making a doing is going around all
you're doing is going around in circles
and circles and trying to make going
around in circles H hey guys in the
comment section which one of us is going
around in circles which one of us is
going around one of us is arguing you
started with ar make point you you
started with the AR make Point while
ices while I was search while I was
searching for my sources you're like oh
tell me about how is the gospel changed
while I was searching my forces you're
like oh how is this how is this brother
why don't you just me that you don't
have anything bro you don't have nothing
you don't have nothing if you don't have
the Bible without Bible you have nothing
aldah I have I don't believe the Trinity
like you like you know believing in
three gods in one that's I don't have
that I don't have that confusion every
day I don't have to have that confusion
every day in my life be like oh who
should I pray to who should I pray to
should I pray to the father Jesus or the
Holy Spirit I believe in one God I
believe in one God believe you're
unarian you're a Unitarian you're a
unarian are are you a trinitarian are
you a trinitarian orar no simple
question are you a Unitarian or you
believe in the Trinity 3 in one three in
one you I'm asking you in one are you
are you you multile Gods I believe in I
believe in are you smiling yet I believe
in you don't know means if you don't
even know what means if you think God
can have a son you don't know you don't
you don't even know what if you
believe if you can't three in one every
time all right thanks for coming man
keep keep clicking you made no point you
made no point right you're right you're
right I I made no point I just showed
how it is inevitable no matter how you
guys come no matter what tactic you try
to come with and approach the situation
approach the conversation you all get
exposed as being robots it never fails